how are you during quarantine what are
you doing how are you handling it first
of all how are you handling the
quarantine
well let me put it like this i've been
in atlanta since march 14 when we shut
down my show i was shooting a show with
netflix
and i shut it down i'm glad because i'm
health conscious and i came to atlanta
i'm handling it i'm
i'm locked up i'm locked down i'm
quarantined i'm
insulated isolated whatever i don't go
anywhere
nobody's come to my home i don't let
anybody in um
every now and then all that like sara
lee and jimmy dean
[Laughter]
old friends ben and jerry uh jack
daniels can come over
you know you want you want the good
friends to come over yeah i appreciate
it
but yeah i've been handling pretty well
but i've changed my living habits
i'm just too cautious and uh social
distancing like
not too long ago my daughter came by to
see me
and i live on the 25th floor and uh and
she was in the parking lot across the
street i waved at my ass and i said hey
as close as you're gonna get social
distancing see you keep moving
keep moving so some things have changed
with me conan my
my grooming is not that good uh really
my feet man when i when i'm able to
get a pedicure i'm gonna have to
probably stop by home depot and we're
talking about sand paper
chisel and a jackhammer
you'll need a buzz saw you'll need a
buzz saw you're going to need
[Laughter]
so this pandemic has been bad but i've
been it allows me to
stay at home and write jokes i like
writing jokes i can tell you're
you're loaded for barry you've got a ton
of good stuff